bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo su è più visto ragazzi
abbiamo raggiunto la decima puntata di
happy with e in onore di questa puntata
qui ho deciso di fare un episodio un po
più diverso dal solito raga mela avevate
chiesto in tanti vi parlo oggi farò un
episodio di è più giocando i livelli che
voi avete fatto per me raga
avevate chiesto in tantissimi di farlo
diciamo per farlo un po come uno
speciale di happy meals così per essere
arrivati alla decima puntata
spero vi piaccia come episodio sono
veramente tantissimi livelli vostri aver
haga direi di iniziare con un livello a
caso proprio preso così il primo st per
world trooper fa vigeva e ce la facciamo
se uccidi tutti sei un po vj non sono io
fa vj dispiace proprio zero oggi da di
tutti e due spade o lanciato due e ho
vinto sei ancora convinto che io non sia
po vj hem a lei però non finisce livello
cioè cosa devo farlo buttarmi giù
forse dovevo uccidermi anch'io ho visto
che ha detto di uccidere tutti non lo so
comunque abbiamo avanti per farvi genio
ma andiamo parti veloce laica perché
sono tantissimi ma icon steve ok raga
allora devo riuscire
[Musica]
no no non ci credo non ci voglio credere
a quanto stavano a ma non ci voglio
credere la mio dio cosa avevo fatto cosa
maledizione cazzo di al piani non ha
senso
arrivò qualche cosa oddio cos'è cos'è
oh mio dio cosa cazzo sta che cazzo
ragazzi sono ancora vivo attaccato
all'ampio ne è una cosa fa dai che ci
arrivo che il piede dai che ci arriva
allungati steam tratta una caccia una
scritta che non riesco a lei ho vinto
cos'è sta roba
vabbè andiamo lo stesso io non ai danni
che cosa sia non c'è il suo nome a raga
praticamente ogni impossible non mi
sembra così difficile
sempre se io riesca addio
in the box per farvi jeio che ai ragazzi
questo mi ispira devo non cos'è in the
box per fa vj entra nella scatola non mi
sembra così difficile come livello
aspettate un attimo sembra che io riesca
a scendere la qui sopra maledizione
steve un colpo d'anca dallo se ce la fai
è un po pv ok aspettate oddio cos'è la
fan cola e imposti allora aspettata un
secondo mai
no no che il dio attaccato ma si può
allora ragazzi devo tirarmi by steve se
ce lo fa ok ma era così c'è ovviamente
era una specie di ascensore tra
virgolette ok poi vj supera questo anche
lui mistica ragazzi tutti che visti cano
e loro pensano che io non ci riesca ma
non sanno che io questa tattica
cosa sta facendo e ragga mi sto mi sto
praticamente attaccando all'arp ione
cosa cazzo fa cioè io mi sto attaccando
all'azione ma senza dio
cos'è ragazzo addio paranormal lampione
cos'è fantastico prova ci fa vigente
speriamo non siano tutti impossible però
perché se no è che cazzo molecole oddio
oddio no non ci voglio credere
madonna sono ancora vivo però credono
non sono ancora vivo sono appeso rega
sono respinge arpioni il mio pene
maledizione non mi fanno nulla di
arpioni mi hanno preso in 50 fino a ora
però mi hanno fatto niente
sono ancora vivo cazzo
sta godendo cosa vai vai vedere vaio mio
dio mio dio non ci voglio credere
mio dio cosa sto per farlo ragazzi devo
lasciarmi devono pregare di riuscire a
beccare il punto dai se o mio dio non ci
voglio credere
non ci voglio mai steve vai stime
regalami un sogno steve regalami un
sogno vai avanti nostri ti prego non
indietro non indietro steam non indietro
no dai mio dio non ci voglio dai steve
la no no non ci voglio credere al mio
dio ce l'avevo il mio addio ce l'avevo
fatta c'è ma cazzo devi andare dritto
steve non puoi non si può
maledizione si che non si può non ce la
farò mai più cazzo rai che stavo facendo
una cosa epica ma fa ancora slow motion
per famiglia oddio stop motion per fa vj
questo sono curiosissimo cos'è devo
prendere la fai così no ed a far cola
vai e ti prendi la ce la posso fare
poi cos'è maledizione in allenamento e
devo prenderla ma forse non la devo
prenderla devo schivare aspettate nativa
schivo ed scrive la testa già ce l'ho
fatta
sì sono sopravvissuto se mappa per fa vj
raga io questa la gioco soltanto perché
il nome di chi l'ha creata
è fantastico è un bagno ma cosa famiglia
è la cosa piace tanto a fa vj cos'è la
pasta l'ho presa al volo è grande ho
capito che anche tu sai cosa vuol dire
cosa vi ricorda niente questo da che
musica era accompagnata dal party rock è
aspettato sbagliato
ok madonna strofinato su bianca style ok
il video speciale di 15.000 era suo
mi ricordo no no no ma l'inizio
o ancora vivo by step ai 10 spade nel
culo ma ce la puoi fare
ok ok ok l'ho presa stavolta l'ho presa
ok che poi non mi dico assi si era
quello della nutella fino a dio ce l'ho
ancora sullo scaffale così per ricordo
perché non me lo scorderò mai
quel giorno rischiato la vita cos'è cosa
ci sarà ora no non lo so è infatti ne so
io mi addio non puoi far miste domande
posso uscire di qua ce l'ho fatta
ok allora i piccoli in prossimo devo
riuscire ad arrivarci
raga sono riuscito a uscire è ok sono
riuscito a uscire da linus rom è stata
una cosa ma a bastardo no no non ci
voglio solo il mio osso del collo ce la
posso fare
non ci voglio credere ma cosa ma dai ma
si può a raga ma dai ma cos'è fa vj kill
the mall questo mi ispira un casino
cos'è lo faccio poi tutti faccio fuori
vai via
no no sono ancora vivo con una trave nel
culo no veramente non annulla gli hoc
annusa annosa maledetto stronzo cos'è
mai così fai niente come look non servi
a un cazzo non servi a un cazzo cosa fai
se ancora vivo ti passo sopra brutto
stronzo
cos'è vabbè raga impossibile maledizione
tutela per forni j j
questo sarà fantastico mi sento vaio che
suo padre così nutella
[Musica]
ciao farris e riesce a fare questo
livello
io sono già morti gli f16 a fare questo
livello sei un mito oggi è giusto
attenzione al vetro grazie potevi
dirmelo un po dopo
vabbè ma mike ok ok fermi un attimo
fermi fermi amici miei
so che siete messi ben in questo preciso
momento ma devo riuscire a vincere
staccate mila terra brutti stronzi si
sposterà ma è impossibile ragazzi
vai cos'è no mio dio che cosa disastrosa
cosa cazzo
oddio uno spiedino di babbo ed elfi
tutti insieme a ben ci sei quasi è un po
un casino però ho vinto con la testa di
un elfo devo riuscire ad arrivarci non
sa cosa ci dici ragazzi mai così o ai
soggetti dai cazzo e impositiva ai ruoli
chicca perché mi si è ancorata la
sinistra ma edizione poi devo provare a
lasciarmi mai lasciati stronzo se la
città dai dai dai detenere un secret
[Musica]
che culo io la chiudo qui perché sono
veramente tantissimi ci metterei un
secolo raga vi ringrazio veramente di
cuore perché mi delicate tutti questi
livelli come al solito ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione 06
da coristi iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi